We are going to the beach.
It's going to be fun.
A whole long day of sand, water, sun!
Don't forget your bathing suit.
I won't forget my bathing suit.
Don't forget the towels.
I won't forget the towels.
Don't forget the sunscreen.
I won't forget the sunscreen.
We are going to the beach.
It's going to be fun.
A whole long day of sand, water, sun!
Don't forget the beach ball.
I won't forget the beach ball.
Don't forget the pail and shovel.
I won't forget the pail and shovel.
Don't forget the sunglasses.
I won't forget the sunglasses.
We are going to the beach.
It's going to be fun.
A whole long day of sand, water, sun!
Don't forget a sun hat.
I won't forget a sun hat.
Don't forget a snorkel.
I won't forget a snorkel.
Don't forget your sandals.
I won't forget my sandals.